thanks to our friends at point spend i
have no idea how to take that
and turn it into what we're going to do
but points bet
for 2021 the win totals projected
the over under prop bet that you can
make now and we spotted some yesterday
that
to me look pretty ripe like the saints
at nine are you kidding me the saints
are gonna win more than nine games this
year hashtag old takes exposed
the rams at ten and a half i really like
that one some of the others that we
talked about yesterday i like let's see
what we like or don't like
in the afc and let's begin with the
champions of the conference and the
two-time
well the two-time champions of the
conference that's what i was trying to
say so i said it
kansas city 12. that's the highest
number we've seen so far
12 wins for the chiefs projects to 12
and 5.
these are all based on 17 games i'm not
surprised
by that i'm not surprised by it at all
chris i would expect
the chiefs to win more than 12 games in
2021
despite the issues that they've had i i
mean i i'm with you i think yes
i mean yeah at 12 games in a 17 game
season
you know again with with what they have
on the offensive side of the ball
and just how special mahomes is and
everything like that
yeah i'm expecting them still to be one
of the best teams in the afc
and we've seen again the last few years
the defense continues to
you know be solid you know
it's not like it's like it was five
years ago where you just went man the
offense or
they got a score we don't know if the
defense really can stop anybody i mean
the defenses
they have a presence on that football
team they do make plays
so yeah even though it's still swayed to
the offensive side of the ball i still
look at kansas city as certainly being
one of the
the best teams in the afc i i'm i'm
surprised to see the chargers
yes that's the shocker there right
that's nine and eight i think they're
going to be better than nine and eight
with brandon taylor with justin herbert
in year two if they can keep some guys
healthy and that's always the if with
the chargers
and i continue to say when you've got
these injury issues that play out over
time at some point you really have to
take a step back and look at what your
organization is doing to get guys ready
to keep guys healthy it isn't just bad
luck
we see guys get pretzeled up all the
time on sundays and they pop up
and they keep going and the chargers
have to find a way to get their
their guys healthy and keep them healthy
if they can do that they're going to
sail past
nine chris i mean yes
it's a it's like again it's total
projection but i i think you know what
you know sportsbook is telling us here a
little bit is like wait look at this
team there's a lot to like here
i mean there is i mean when you look at
the offense it was one of the better
offenses in football last year we know
they got a star quarterback
they got good receivers they've tried to
improve their offensive line this off
season gave the big money to corey
linsley
you know signed matt filer from the the
steelers so they're trying to be
you know help that part of their team
and as we talked about last year too
the defense is damn good i mean it was a
top 10 defense in football
all year long so i think if you take
away some of the management of games and
some of the crazy things that happened
to them last year
you look at them and go wait they could
have won nine games last year in a lot
of ways or at least been right around
500 or something like that
uh so i'm i'm i'm with you there i look
at the chargers to be that team that
didn't make the playoffs that are
certainly
gonna be in the playoff conversation for
2021.
and the other thing to keep in mind all
of the four teams in the afc
west will play in addition to the
two each round rob and they play every
team from the afc north which is one of
the tougher divisions in football
every team from the nfc east which means
fatten up
the four teams from the afc west and
that
17th game and and i i've noticed some
confusion out there and i think
pete texted this last night the 17th
game doesn't mean it's the last game of
the season the last game of the season
what is up with that game what is up
with people people think that the 17th
game is the last game that is just
like putting the tail on the donkey it
just means it's the
extra game the game that wouldn't have
been played it could be week one
it could be week five it could be week
12 it could be week
17 not week 18. it won't be your last
game of the season
but uh the the chiefs pick up
the packers in that inner conference
game the champions of the nfc north
the chargers by virtue of finishing
third
in the afc west will play the vikings
who are the third place so
that's another area where it's a little
easier for the chargers a little tougher
for the chiefs and surely that's a
factor in these projections by points
bet
yeah i i i would think so and you know
and and of course
you know just going back to the chargers
again
you look at them i mean how many games
realistically did they blow
at the end of the game at the end of the
game last year really i mean they were a
seven and nine football team
that easily i mean could have been
10 10 and six maybe even 11 and five i
mean there were so many games where you
just went i can't believe they found a
way to lose that game
that is unbelievable they lost it they
outplayed that team for 58 minutes 58
and a half minutes
and they lose uh so there's there's
great potential for that chargers
football
team and i'm with you yeah it helps you
know the vikings that's
uh to win chalk it up chalk it up for
the chargers win
ultimately ultimately got i i hear you
ultimately got anthony lynn fired and
brandon staley who
won rave reviews in his one year as the
defensive coordinator of the la rams
staying in the same stadium not just in
the same city but in the same venue and
has an opportunity
to make that team into something it
hasn't been in a very
long time and yeah i think nine is low
for them how about
the las vegas raiders at seven and a
half
they were eight and eight last year
again this is based on 17 games if they
fall
under seven wins if they go 6
and 11 or worse i don't know what it
means for john gruden i still think it's
going to take a lot for mark davis to
fire his buddy
i i really do and i think mark davis is
content
for john gruden to be the coach of the
team
the team's been bad for what almost 20
years now
you can be bad and not have john gruden
or you can be bad and have john gruden i
don't think that
that that this is a hot seat year for
john groot and i don't care how bad they
may be
and there's still a chance they're going
to be pretty good i just don't know
right now they fall into that category
of i don't know what to make of them
because of all the changes that they've
made specifically along their offensive
line oh i know it's a hard team to get a
feel for as we sit here in april
it might be one of those things where
you have to revisit this conversation
after the draft
see what holes they fill those type of
things but yeah there's the questions on
the o-line
excuse me we know that you know they did
give colton miller
that big contract they resigned richie
incognito
right they signed the center nick martin
so they got him so they filled some of
those holes but yeah it's it's a little
bit hard to get a feel for them
and then you look on the defensive side
of the ball and i think we're still
sitting there having the same
conversation we did
you know at the end of the year it's
just like you know what what is there
who's what part of the defense is the
difference maker what part is special
where is it going to come from the
production the plays those type of
things so
i i'm with you i don't think gruden's
butt is on the hot seat
i don't you know maybe if they went 13-3
and it was a disaster
do i think he could maybe be in trouble
okay i still think he'd probably get the
benefit of another year
you know to their they're in the process
they've rolled out the red carpet to let
him get this team where he wants
and it's obviously not there yet but
there's still yeah a lot of question
marks about this football team
not sure where they're going right now
afc east the buffalo bills were the
champions last year points ben has the
bills at
10 and a half wins a little bit of a
surprise
from 13-3 to either 10 and 7 or 11 and
six
i would expect the bills to still be
pretty good they will have that first
place schedule
and they will have a better rest of the
division this year that's where it gets
interesting
for buffalo patriots better dolphins
likely better
jets new quarterback who could be great
right out of the gates who knows after
that two robert
solomon last year yeah yeah so uh
i i i you know it it my first thought
with buffalo was that seems a little low
but then when you start broadening it a
bit
and you consider the rest of the
schedule you consider they are going to
have those three first place games
not two anymore but there's three games
now that are driven by where you
finished
it could make it a little harder for
buffalo and and they're going to be
in a tougher position to take anyone by
surprise
next year this past year there was a
little element of that we didn't expect
this from the bills
there'll be a team that gets circled a
little more strongly
by the opponents and that even though
it's like oh that doesn't matter in a
long season it does matter there are
teams that you take seriously
there are teams that you say ah and
they're no longer a team that you look
at and say
ah yeah no you're right the they're here
when you have a quarterback like that
everybody's gonna be watching you or
ready for you and you come to town
uh so i'm with you there you know got to
play the nfc south the afc
south you know some tough games there
but i think ultimately the big thing too
like
is what you're saying mike the division
has gotten better
i mean it's it's really good it's i'm
excited to watch the afc east football
this year
you know again i'm a huge fan of what
new england did to improve their
football team
and i think we're both big fans of what
miami's been doing and doing to to kind
of
get them to be a a perennial power so uh
i still think the bills are really good
but yeah there's there's more
competition there
this year and i think the big thing with
the bills too more than anything
you know we know their offense is in a
great spot uh
it's a special quarterback but you know
i i i look at their defense still
to go hey it's good you know they got
leslie
leslie frazier and sean mcdermott
coaching it and they do a lot of
awesome stuff on that side of the ball
but they could use another
playmaker difference maker something
somewhere in the
on the front four maybe in this you know
maybe another corner i don't know but i
would like to see them get a pass rusher
or some disrupter up front to really
help their team
it ultimately was the offense that got
stymied by the ravens in
uh in the postseason when the bills
finally saw their run
come to an end oh wait a minute no am i
lost in the championship it was the
other way around yeah it was a tough
game it was remember it was ten three
two right down it was a game where
exactly then he threw that i missed
remember
yeah it's okay i apologize a lot's
happened in the past few months
it was a very windy night it was very
long and the bill's offense still was
not as impressive in that game
the ravens did a good job of stymieing
the offense uh the offense that was so
high-powered that's my effort to save
my blunder uh blunders in new england
galore last year leading to a 7-9 record
they have gone all out to make the team
better i see that nine sitting there
chris
and i say wow i think the pit nine and
eight for the patriots this year
i'll i'll go over nine and eight for the
patriots when you consider
that they still managed to win seven
games with a roster that was so
overmatched the week in and week out
willing of the team to be better than
the individual parts may be
i could see the patriots not necessarily
catching the bills maybe they will
but but getting the double-digit wins i
think that's
that's an easy that's an easy yes sign
me up for that proposition i i'm
i'm i'm there with you big guy all the
way i mean with that coaching staff the
way they set
you know set their game plans up
you know and of course the way they
coach their football teams and now you
got talent to go along with that
and again a talent that i think fits
what they want to do
they don't give a damn what the rest of
the world thinks and all these type of
things
they have a plan as far as how they want
to play
and the style of football they want to
play and i think all these guys they've
gotten
even though maybe not be the sexiest
names are really damn good football
players they're going to help them
accomplish their goal
to play a certain way and i think you're
going to see a different cam newton this
year
so i i mean i'm with you i think new
england
they have a resurgence back to the top
of football this year
and i expect them to be in a dog fight
with with the buffalo bills to win the
afc east i don't think i'm just going to
give the afc's crown to
the bills for a second year in a row the
dolphins won 10 games last year in a 16
game season they are at nine this year
in a 17 game season
i can't help but regard that as
a vote of no confidence in tuatanga
viola now that his relief
pitcher ryan fitzpatrick isn't there i i
mean i think so too i think there's a
little bit like hey we all like the team
and all of that you know but again even
with two of winning games they were
managed perfectly last year in a lot of
ways the defense made a lot of big plays
to help out those type of things
i think we're just not sure about them
you know again we know we can win games
and do stuff like that
but you know for quarterback and
especially playoff caliber teams and
things like that it's like those one or
two games where you go man our team
didn't play good
but damn our quarterback was awesome he
got us over the hump today
we won a game we we didn't play our best
football and i think that's the big
question about them
you know and then the other thing too is
just what do they get to help them out
is number six pick gonna be that wide
receiver that explosive element on
offense that
they do miss they need they need one
more stud muffin there
to help them out on that on that side of
the ball defense is pretty damn good
um so it's all about tua to me it's
about
can he make plays can they open up the
offense this year around him
to scare people and not have to play
this
wait we got to take care of him we got
to run the ball and defense i hope you
hold them under 20 or around there and
we're not going to win the game
that to me i just don't think it's
realistic two years in a row and i think
that's where
you know you see this this line being a
little questionable
the jets at six and a half caught my
attention considering they were two and
fourteen last year for the most part
these numbers seem
a little high there's a little optimism
infused into them we know that there
will be teams that go
under the number there will be teams
that win three or four
or two or maybe even one game in a 17
game season who knows
but this shows that
vegas believes in where the jets are
heading yeah what they've done by hiring
robert sala and also
this assumption that that they're
upgrading at quarterback
to go from six from two to six and a
half maybe more i i
i wouldn't rule it out i don't know that
i'd sign on for the over
six and a half i'm just surprised that
that's where the number is i i would be
hesitant about going over
five and a half or maybe even four and a
half if i
if i were were betting on this just
because the jets still have a lot of
work to do there's no guarantee they're
going to come out of the gates
especially in a division like this
and be dramatically better than they
were in only one year
no i mean it is it's a tough division i
do think the new energy of
salah the new quarterback all of those
things are positives for
for the franchise they've made some
great free agent signings
you know during that period that that
like players that fit the way
they want to play football you know
especially on the defensive side of the
ball with jared davis you're gonna have
him with mosley and middle linebacker
whoa that's pretty damn good you know
you go out
and they got a carl lawson a legit pass
rusher off the edge
lamarcus joyner they made sure they keep
marcus may you know those things make
sense for their football team
yeah i don't know if i'd like bet money
uh that that they would go over that six
and a half mike but
i mean i i certainly think they're gonna
flirt with it for sure
and they get another weapon wide
receiver in the draft with zach wilson
to go along with that you know
offense of what they're going to do
there uh
they got some potential they got
something growing there and i'm excited
to see zach wilson in that jets uniform
afc north the steelers uh
are are down as expected the ravens
finished 11-5 last year they did not win
the division they are projected based on
win total to do so this year with that
11
number on a 17-game season i think that
seems about right the competition
increasing
in the division and uh you know the
the ravens um a team that that
i never can get a good handle on when i
think they're bad
they turn it around when i buy in they
find a way to fall apart
um i don't know what their ceiling is
this year they're one of the better
teams in the conference and i think 11
bears that out you know there's just
there's just four teams
that that have that double digit
projected win total so i i
it feels right to me yeah and it's one
that i would avoid
trying to guess over or under on no i
mean
you know i i i'm i'm with i mean i would
expect them to be right there
and still really a big time player in
the afc still
you know at the end of the day the the
roster is just too damn good to think
they're just going to fall by the
wayside and then you add that to
john harbaugh and oh wait we have a
special quarterback who make plays
you know even you know it was a down
year last year and they were 11 and 5.
that that's where the ravens have come
to so uh i look at them as still being a
major player but that division is
real i mean as we know cleveland those
days are over the browns ain't the
browns anymore
that's they can beat baltimore they can
beat pittsburgh as we
know and then of course hey what's
pittsburgh going to be with big ben
there's those questions joe burrow his
health
how effective can he be early on in the
year if he comes back like
all systems go early on in the season
hey the
bengals are they're going to be a pain
in the butt for these football teams
they could add a loss to the schedule
something like that
great division here a lot of talent but
i'm still going to go with baltimore as
the king
the bengals the only team in the
division who have a projected win total
higher than what they had last year and
again the 17 game season
accounting for some of the difference
the steelers from 12 and four
down to an eight and five projection and
and and you know that feels
just about right on the money from the
standpoint of i have no idea whether i'd
go
above or below that because it's just
flat even
when some lose some they could be
dramatically better they could be
dramatically worse
but as of right now that that just
they're just
kind of there it is yeah i know i mean
why why what do you think like
vegas you know sportsbook anything here
is looking at points bet like what are
they looking at with pittsburgh to make
them really question it
it's just the way i think it's the
offense it's got to be the offense right
it's got to be the offense and
the 11-game winning streak was inflated
by so many games that they easily could
have lost and
you do get credit for ultimately winning
those games but ben roethlisberger
now 39 just because he was healthy last
year doesn't mean he's going to be
healthy this year he had the knee issues
that we continued to hear about all year
long even though he wasn't on the injury
report it could just be it's a
degenerative
arthritic type of a condition there's
nothing they can do about it we can't
treat it there's nothing to do
you just gotta gut it out who's their
starting running back going to be
right what's their offensive line going
to look like absolutely
are they going to have an offensive
attack that makes sense
last year yeah they threw the ball a lot
but it didn't
allow them to win games when they needed
to win games and it caused their offense
to sputter because it was all
or at least mostly short passes i think
it's the offense that drags down the
perception of this team the defense is
still fine
yeah and the thing about the steelers
when the when the expectations are low
that is when they find a way
to defy them so uh you know
this this may be setting up for the
steelers to just have a sneaky kind of a
great year as we write them off and
i still think that the best move would
have been to move on from ben
rothenberger just because even if they
have a good year they're not going to be
a super bowl team i think that's really
what it comes down to
if you're holding the band together in
the hopes that you can get a super bowl
out of this group
i think that there are fundamental
difference between 2021
and 2005 when they held it together for
one more year with jerome bettis and won
the super bowl and then the next year
was
bill cower's swan song and they finally
got him a super bowl they finally got
their fifth ring
everything was set up for that from a
talent standpoint i feel like they
they have a gap between them and at a
minimum the chiefs
and the bills and and possibly the
ravens and who knows maybe the way the
browns are going
maybe there's a talent gap if you throw
out the helmets and the names and the
histories
maybe you could say the browns position
by position average player
better than the steelers yeah i mean
listen you said a lot of things that i
agree with
you know the the steelers you know first
off i think you're totally right
it's all about the offense of course it
is the defense is special
i mean it's a superstar defense you know
it really is i mean they got everything
you want yeah they lost bud dupree that
that's going to hurt them but
they got pretty good replacements there
as far as guys that are good
serviceable let's not forget you know
devin bush got hurt the middle
linebacker last year who's so important
to that scheme and everything like that
so it is it's just about like what are
they going to do on offense
you know you know you're right like
they're it's like hey we're going to try
to
maybe change the way we play or do
change something
i don't know were they capable it's not
like they had a lot of money in free
agency to assign different players on
their team and change the outlook of
their offense all together
it is going to be about that attitude
and the one thing i'll say too
is you know mike tomlin the steelers
they're they're renegades
so that to you like what you're saying
where it's like expectations aren't high
and everybody's sleeping on them
you know they are the kind of group
that'll get chippy and oh yeah we can't
run the ball and do those things and
they'll take interest in
you know putting full pads on in
training camp and doing those type of
things
but i think the offense are all the
questions yeah
big ben where is he at can that
offensive line block and can they be
more balanced because it's crazy the way
they played last year asking him to drop
back that many times
and yeah can they have a running back
that's that's a real difference maker
that's the big question yeah it's great
receivers but we can't throw it every
play there's got to be something else
with a 39 year old quarterback and
and i'm with you mike i think that's got
to be the big question there the ability
of mike tomlin the coach of that team
who is so incredibly well respected
among his peers to get the absolute most
out of whatever he has
2019 they lose roethlisberger week two
in that game against the seahawks and
and he and he tomlin nearly wills them
to the playoffs
that was amazing and and i just think it
it
now that the expectations are kind of
bottoming out i think that
that the steelers if they can keep
keep players like roethlisberger healthy
uh
they could they could surprise us with
what they do in 2021 the afc south
the indianapolis colts uh and the
tennessee titans both 11 and 5
last year this year a little gap
between the colts and tennessee the
colts who picked up carson wentz
in that trade with the eagles last month
uh with 10
wins projected and and that i i
when you you know it all comes down to
wentz but i could see them winning more
than 10 games if wence is the guy that
he was before 2020 yeah i could see it
happen chris
i i can too i mean i think a base level
like the colts have the most complete
roster
in the afc south i think it to me it
would be hard to argue that right now
you know we know they got pretty good
receivers yeah you know they need
you know guys like paris campbell to be
healthy and help them out the running
back's awesome
offensive line you know really damn good
you know they're gonna figure out i
don't know maybe they'll get an upgrade
or draft somebody in the draft for left
tackle they have guys there that could
certainly hold down the fort in the
meantime
defense it's a top 10 defense so i mean
you look at everything that way
and you just go hey the colts the colts
got it all they really do they're really
close
they are in the super bowl window
there's no doubt mike the same thing
like
i'll go back with them you know there's
there's a lot to
love and like about their team there's
only one area i just wish they had a
little bit more production or disruption
or whatever you want to say
and that's just you know i wish they
could find a a real big time pass rusher
off the edge with the way they play in
that kind of seattle scheme
they don't want to blitz a whole lot you
know they are dependent on that pass
rush
uh that that be the only thing i can
look at on a pretty well-built football
team that i could go i wish that was
better other than that it's all pretty
damn good
jacksonville was one in 15. whoa they
are like the jets at a six and a half
projected win total urban meyer and
trevor lawrence is that enough
to create that bump they added a bunch
of free agents none of them are
superstar caliber it's all due respect
trevor lawrence
urban meyer does that allow you
to say this team can be good enough to
get close to six wins or maybe get more
i i that that's a that's a tough one i
mean i i don't know if the urban meyer
trevor lawrence bump is worth five games
right
i mean i know we got the extra game this
year and all those type of things but
i mean there's just so many you know one
what is the offense really going to look
like
you know is it going to be an urban
meyer ecology
type offense i think so he's got guys
like daryl bevel there of course who
have been in the nfl for a long time
i i mean yeah right now that's just a
total projection on
energy the quarterback hey good free
agent signings but i don't think
anything that blows us out of the water
there
i have no idea with jacksonville what
they're going to be but at least is
exciting we know that
with the two new guys and the head coach
and the quarterback that's going to give
that fan base and
and city you know some some fun times in
the future
it's amazing how overlooked trevor
lawrence has been just because we regard
it as a given there's no mystery
it's been set up for for multiple years
yeah since we saw what he did as a
freshman
we knew he was going to be the first
pick and now it's all these other guys
we're talking about zach wilson
thanks to you mac jones thanks to you
others
thanks to you and others and we're those
are the guys we're focused on yeah cause
it's like the haze in the barn on trevor
lawrence
and at some point it's like oh yeah
they're going to play football games
there's a chance he's going to be really
good there's a chance he's going to
elevate this jaguars team there's a
chance they're going to win more than
six and a half games yeah in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports